I'm Dr Chris Rainer and I've been an
orthopedic surgeon for the last 15 years
I'm going to talk about every bone in
the body by looking at the brakes cracks
and injuries from John Wayne
humans are actually born with a few more
bones but as they mature some of those
bones fuse together so that the number
is reduced if you think of a bone it's
kind of like an egg it has a very hard
outer shell which is the cortex of the
bone the inside actually looks more like
sponge you can actually squeeze it
together and compress it there is liquid
blood and fat and so when you break a
bone it bleeds a lot
the skull
the occipital bone the occipital bone is
located in the back of the cranium in
John Wick we see him getting whacked in
the head with a bat getting hit in the
occipital bone is not necessarily going
to be more painful than any other bone
in the head but you will have forward
flexion of the cervical spine as a
result that in and of itself could cause
injuries in the neck region the parietal
bone the parietal bones are located on
the side of the cranium so the terion is
the point at which the parietal bone is
the thinnest and it's the most
susceptible part of that bone to injury
if you injure the bone in this area
there is a good chance that you could
injure the middle meningeal artery which
lies directly below and you can cause a
hematoma which could affect the flow of
blood in that artery the temporal bones
are on the side of the cranium if you're
going to hit him in the head it would be
one of the best places to do it the
frontal bone is at the front of the
cranium anytime you have a head injury
or a head blow with significant amount
of force you run the risk of concussion
there isn't a set amount of force that
is required to give a concussion if
varies from person to person the
sphenoid bone these are the cavities
that hold your eyeballs and the sphenoid
basically produces the back of that
structure the C note is an irregularly
shaped bone so if you were to take it
out and isolate it it looks like either
a bat or a butterfly the ethmoid bone
the ethmoid bone is located just above
and behind the nasal bone so you can't
really see it from the outside of your
face and it produces a roof over the
nasal cavity the nasal bone the nasal
bones are basically located at the top
portion of your nose where your nose
meets your face we definitely see some
slaps and punches to the face in John
Wick Palatine bone the Palatine bone is
an essential structure in the oral and
nasal cavity of the skull this bone can
be injured in association with mid
facial or pan facial fractures the
zygomatic Bones the zygomatic bones
forms the upper portion of your
cheekbone as it comes towards the side
of the eye the infant inferior nasal
Concho this helps to filter the air that
we breathe vomer this separates the
right and left nasal cavities the
lacrimal bonds the lacrimal bones
basically make up the inner portion of
the orbit so they're just above the
nasal Bones the lacrimal bones are the
most fragile bones in the face because
they are very thin plate-shaped bones so
in the event that you actually hit
somebody hard enough in the nose there
is a possibility that you can cause a
very significant injury the nasal bones
would then be forced up through the
ethmoid which we said already is a very
spongy bone up into the brain case
that's above when that happens to John
Wick that might end up being a problem
maxilla basically the upper portion of
your face
the mandible so the mandible is the
bottom half of your jaw the mandible is
the strongest bone in the skull with
your mandible you could bite through
smaller bones in the hand or in the feet
you'd be hard-pressed to be able to bite
through larger bones in your forearm or
leg or anything like that but small
bones you could bite through for sure
the bones of the middle ear the malleus
incus and stapus the bones of the inner
ear are the smallest bones of the body
these are the bones that help us to
transduce sound waves neck
hyoid bone the hyoid bone is the only
bone in the body that doesn't directly
articulate with any other bonds because
it doesn't really articulate with
anything doesn't really have any
protection so if you grab the neck and
you apply any significant Force to the
neck then you could break that bone when
we see John Wick with a plastic bag over
his head there is a possibility that his
hyoid could be injured the force would
have to be directed more posteriorly to
actually fracture the hyoid it's a very
small and delicate bone so it's not
something that's very easily repaired
and generally speaking for most cases
where the hyoid bone is injured we will
try to allow it to heal using
non-operative means spine
when we were born we have about 33
vertebrae as we mature the bones of the
sacrum and the caustics use to one
another and so instead of being
individual bones they end up being one
solid bone so we end up with a total of
24 vertebrae they are the cervical spine
the thoracic spine the lumbar spine and
the sacral spine the cervical vertebrae
when compared to other vertebrae in the
spine the cervical vertebrae are
certainly much smaller in size and more
delicate this just makes sense because
the amount of weight that the cervical
spine is supporting is significantly
less than other parts of the spine
typical Trope is that they like to twist
the head and instantaneously kill people
I'm not sure that that's the most
efficient way but c345 keeps the
diaphragm alive so if you can break the
neck above the C3 level that is going to
be ultimately fatal if the person
doesn't get medical attention the
thoracic vertebrae the lumbar vertebrae
in the movie when John is thrown off the
balcony he lands on his back I have to
tell myself as an orthopedic surgeon to
suspend some disbelief because there is
a very highly significant chance that he
would have suffered a fracture of his
lumbar spine and in fact probably more
than just his lumbar spine he probably
would have fractured other parts of his
spine as well the lumbar vertebrae are
significantly larger than are the
vertebrae in either the cervical or the
thoracic spine because they are
supporting much more weight than are the
other vertebrae of the spine the sacrum
the sacrum is the bottom most portion of
the spine and this is a solid bone that
previously when we were embryos was a
segmented portion of the spine but it is
now fused to become one solid bone the
coccyx the cossix is the end most
portion of the spinal column it's the
bottom portion of the sacrum and it's
basically a vestigial tail it's
otherwise known as the tailbone the
tailbone is not really protected by
anything if you look at most of the
other bones other than at joints those
bones are surrounded by a significant
amount of of soft tissue including
muscle and fat but if you touch your
tailbone there's not really anything
between the tailbone and the hard
surface that you're going to impact
other than a small layer of skin when
you land on your tailbone you are
hitting your tailbone directly onto the
floor and that's why it's painful
the chest
sternum the sternum is a flat bone that
resides in the middle of your chest
right about there the sternum plays an
integral role in helping to create
stability of your chest cavity it's the
location where the ribs wrap around your
torso and then they connect with the
sternum so the sternum in conjunction
with the ribs and then the spine and
behind gives the thorax or the chest
cavity it's strength and rigidity
generally speaking no bone is going to
protect you against a bullet most
bullets are traveling fast enough to
break a bone in the John Wick series he
has the benefit of a suit that has a
Kevlar layer in it which is like a
bulletproof vest which will help to
dissipate some of the energy so that
you're less likely to penetrate the
chest cavity the clavicle the clavicle
is located at the top of the chest in
between the shoulder joint and the
sternoclavicular joint it is a bone that
is injured quite frequently when we fall
we have a tendency to want to protect
ourselves and put our hands out and if
we fall to the side that bone ends up
striking the ground on an angle so each
of those fractures we're basically going
to treat the same way we're going to
expose the bone which is what's called
an open reduction under direct
visualization we're going to take those
two fracture fragments bring them back
to one another we are going to
provisionally hold them in place usually
with a small pin which is called the K
wire and then we will take a precontour
word plate which we will then place on
top of the bone put screws on either
side of the fracture and then we'll
secure those screws to stabilize that
bone when a bone comes through the skin
this is what is known as a open fracture
bones do bleed bones are like the
assembly line for blood production that
is where blood cells are born inside the
marrow of the bone in some trauma
situations where we cannot get a good
intravenous line in patients we will
actually run IV fluids into the bone it
doesn't work as effectively as if you
had an intravenous line but in the event
that we can get no other lines we can
actually put an intra-osseous catheter
and keep you alive the scapula the
scapula is is relatively protected it
lays flat against the thoracic cage on
your back and it has a thick layer of
muscle both on the front and the back
surface the shoulder joint is kind of
like the hip joint and that it's a ball
and socket joint however where the hip
joint is an actual socket the shoulder
joint is more of a saucer when you have
a force that is applied too quickly or
when the arm goes beyond its maximum
range of motion sometimes that humeral
head can slide off the face either to
the front or to the back or in rare
circumstances down below or up top and
this is what's called a shoulder
dislocation the ribs generally most
adults have 24 ribs 12 on either side we
see John Wick break more than a few
risks
so when you suffer a rib fracture
there's always a chance that some other
structures normally protected by the
ribs can be injured most likely this is
going to be the lungs those injuries can
be associated with pneumothorax which is
where air can escape the lung but still
sit inside the chest cavity or also a
hemothorax or in some cases a hemo
pneumothorax those are the the kind of
injuries that are most common some
people have extra ribs and this is
basically a congenital deformity if you
will or it was just a spontaneous
mutation so generally speaking the extra
ribs are located in one of two places
either the cervical spine or the lumbar
spine
the arms so they're generally three
bones in the arms we have the upper arm
which is made of the humerus the humerus
bone is the longest bone of the arm and
supports movement in the arm and
shoulder the radius and the ulna the
radius and the ulnar are likely bones to
be fractured and that is a function of
our desire to protect ourselves in the
event that we fall there's no such thing
as a funny bone this is a misnomer what
you have is a nerve it's in very close
proximity to the end of the elbow on the
medial aspect and this is the ulnar
nerve that lies just behind the medial
epicondyle so when you bang your funny
bone what you're doing is you are
banging the nerve which is the ulnar
nerve and you are squishing the ulnar
nerve between the surface that you have
banged and the medial epicondyle
the hand bones
so you have the small irregular bones
which make up the wrist and there are
eight of those and those are called the
carpels the carpal bones of the wrist
are arranged in such a way that there is
a tunnel which is called the carpal
tunnel through this tunnel the nerves
and the tendons flexor tendons of the
wrists are housed a common problem that
people will have if there is any
inflammation that's associated with
these tendons is carpal tunnel syndrome
it takes some time to recover after
carpal tunnel surgery so you may have
transient numbness and pain in your hand
for almost a year after carpal tunnel
release just adjacent to those you have
the five metacarpals the metacarpus is a
group of five bones of the hand between
the phalanges and the carpus that makes
up the Rays of the hand even though the
metacarpal bones are small they are
still classified as long bones the next
grouping of bones are the phalanges are
what people refer to as the fingers the
thumb is a unique digit in that not only
can It flex and extend and but it can
also rotate into a movement that we call
opposition in the savannah we needed to
be able to grasp to climb trees and so
the thumb allows us not only to grasp
with our fingers but is what provides
almost 50 percent of the function of
your hand
it is very easy to lose a finger
actually reattaching a finger is called
a replantation this is a relatively
difficult procedure where we have to
basically reconstruct the joint capsule
to provide stability to the Joint we
then have to reconstruct the nerves and
the blood vessels both arteries and
veins so that there is blood supply to
and from the finger and then we have to
provisionally stabilize that while all
the little structures heal
the pelvic girdle ilium ischium pubius
there are two spaces in between the hip
bones so you have the top of the pelvis
which is called the pelvic Inlet and
that's about this big and then you have
the bottom space which is called the
pelvic outlet and that's about this big
the strongest part of the pelvis is the
acetabulum and this is where the ischium
and the ilium meet and the reason why
this is the strongest is because this is
what makes up the socket of the hip
joint so this is where most of the force
of the hip is distributed one of the
most unique injuries that you can have
to the pelvis is what is called a
Windswept pelvis if you were driving and
then your car were T-boned with a high
enough energy of impact you can not only
push in the near side of the pelvis you
can also push out the opposite side of
the pelvis
the legs
the femur the femur is the largest long
bone of the body and it is also the
strongest bone of the body as it sees
the most compressive force on a daily
basis if you are eating marrow from a
cow it is most likely that you are
eating it from the femur Bond the
equivalent is the femur in the human if
you have a femur fracture you can bleed
two liters of blood out of your femur
into your thigh so almost half your
blood volume the fibula the fibula is
quite commonly used as what we call a
vascularized bone graft we can take bone
from anywhere in the body and move it to
another generally we will do this with
non-vascularized bones so bone that does
not have an active blood source that is
attached to it however with the case of
the fibula a nearby artery perineal
artery can be used to transplant that
bone to another area and at the same
time bring with it a blood vessel that
will improve the likelihood that that
bone will be incorporated at the new
site the tibia the tibia or shin bone is
the second largest bone in the body
after the femur it can be fractured
along its length when kicking hard
objects or when checking kicks with your
leg the patella the patella articulates
with the distal femur it is contained
within the tendons on the front aspect
of the leg so the quadricep tendon
attaches to the top and the patellar
tendon attaches to the bottom those
tendons basically hold the patella in
position so as you bend your knee the
patella will move up and down a groove
on the front of the distal femur which
is called the trochlea and the knee will
be kept in position medial and laterally
by that trochlear Groove and it will
protect the front of the knee
the feet bones
foot bones are interesting in that they
are similar to the bones of the hand
except that these bones are
weight-bearing as such the foot has a
number of arches which help to support
the weight of the foot and to allow it
to move dynamically as we stand and
mobilize the tarsal Bones the tarsal
bones form the posterior aspect of the
arches of the foot the metatarsal Bones
the metatarsal bones are known as the
Rays of the foot and they form the front
half of the arches of the foot the
phalanges the big toe has two phalanges
and the other toes have three in the
past when our ancestors lived in
Savannah where we were climbing and we
needed to hold on to branches and swing
from Branch to Branch we needed to use
not only our hands but also our feet at
that time our feet looked much more like
hands and so they have a lot of bones
with a large number of articulation to
allow them to perform hand like
movements although we still have those
bones our feet no longer function in the
same manner that they did in the past so
when you break the digits of your feet
because the actual digits are so short
there really isn't a lot of bone that's
available for us to fix and normally
when we fix a fracture we want to have
an adequate number of points of fixation
on both sides of the fracture but if the
actual bone that we are fixing is only a
centimeter long what we will tend to do
is splint them to the next adjacent
straight Phalanx where we will buddy
tape them together
that was each and every bone in the body
thanks to John Wick and Captain Jack
marrow I think we got them all and now
for the final send-off
foreign